caitlyn lowry star of teen mom 2
it is so lovely to see your face my hat
is off to you for doing
so very much during this very
unprecedented time i am curious
what is life like at home with you and
for little ones
i mean i have and they're all ages so i
have ten
six three and a newborn and so it's kind
of chaos but
um honestly i perform very well under
pressure so but okay
my oldest is 10. you know i didn't know
how he would be with a newborn crying in
the middle of the night and all of that
and then my six-year-old i was like you
know there are they are six years apart
they have
they're just completely in two different
stages of life but
he loves being a big brother and so i it
really
it really has been great so of course it
begs the question
do you think your family at this point
is complete
or sky's the limit let's keep going
let's keep having more kids
it depends on the day that you ask me
some days i'm like oh i
give me five more babies and some days
i'm like um i think we're good with four
so it just depends you know and i know
this is such a personal question but
is there a part of you that would love
to have a little girl
yeah i think yeah i think there is a
little piece i mean if i never have a
daughter that's also okay but i think
there's definitely a piece of me that
wouldn't mind having one for sure i am
14 weeks and i'm due in july
i just need to put my girl pants on i'm
so annoyed i'm sick of this
so of course we got to get into teen mom
2 season 10
i'm curious what was the most
challenging thing that you had to film
this season
if i'm being totally transparent here i
think that
there was a time where i found out i was
pregnant again
and it wasn't the ideal situation and so
i was like is this the best decision for
me or should i
consider abortion and and
and furthermore i was upset that i even
put myself in a position
where i was when i was 16 and pregnant
because i feel like those were some of
the same things that i was
thinking about when i was 16 and so fast
forward 10 years later i'm making the
same mistake
so i think that that was really really
difficult for me
[Music]
as a whole my hat is off to you for
always being so honest and and truthful
with yourself
you know you just called yourself out
for like i'm in the same position that i
was when i was 16
and here you are at 28. um how do you
think you got yourself
into that same position i mean i am
human um
and i think that even though i'm in
therapy and doing a lot of the things
that i needed to be doing and still need
to continue
i do think that i'm human and i still
make mistakes i still
and there are times where i'm going to
take two steps back but
it's just having the self-awareness that
okay i did make the same mistake so now
i need to get back
on track so then if there is a next time
you think it'll be with someone who you
are madly in love with very committed
to and you just want to expand your
family together
100 when i then my next if there are
if there is another one i want it to be
100
like i want to do this this is something
i don't want to have to question my
decision
you know i don't want to have to feel
the same things that i felt
you know with this pregnancy or even my
pregnancy when i was 16.
what made you ultimately decide i don't
want to go through with terminating the
pregnancy talk to me a little bit about
your
your decision-making process i did go to
an abortion appointment and i said to
the
to the tech i said i know that you
normally wouldn't show me
the ultrasound because someone would be
here to terminate i said but i just
don't know that i'm set in my decision
and i need to see this baby on the
screen because one i
i need it to feel real i need to look at
this and really
understand the magnitude of what i'm
about to go through with
and i just want to make sure that i'm
doing what's best for me and i once i
saw this
little baby on the screen i said i'm i
can't do this and
and i know that i'm capable of being a
mom of
four and i know i'm capable of being a
good mom of four so
i'm gonna walk out of here and i'm gonna
feel good in my decision and this
is my decision and and that's what i did
was chris part of the conversation
um he wasn't part of the conversation
but i had
let him and family members know that
this was something that i was
considering
i wasn't giving them a say but i was
letting them know that this is something
that i'm thinking about doing
and what was their reaction i think
there was a little bit of like
uncertainty um but i wasn't going to let
that
ultimately decide what i wanted and what
was best for for myself and for my other
children
i'm proud of myself because i and i have
absolutely no regrets i love my son
i i'm just thankful that i that i
listened to myself and i made the
decision
i made so that's where i'm at i want to
do a little
kind of men in your life roundup um just
to see where everything is currently at
um we know you're we know your
relationship with chris has been very
bumpy from the get-go
how are things with chris today
we don't communicate at all um i don't
hear from him i
i don't i wish him the best
technically he could if he reached out
he could have supervised visits but he
hasn't reached out since creed was born
how much time have they spent together a
couple hours
um collectively how does that make you
feel
it makes me sad for creed because he
won't have the relationship
that well and looks they won't have a
relationship with their dad that isaac
and lincoln have with their dads but at
the same
time i wouldn't want them to have a
relationship with their dad
in in the point of life that chris is at
right now
when chris is healthy and happy and
successful and ready to
actually open those doors to have a real
relationship with his kids
then by all means but until that happens
i can't have the in and out and the
instability and
and i just can't have that i know
obviously creed is is too little at this
point but
lux is three does he ask for dad ever
he does he asks for his dad um what do
you say
i say something similar to what i tell
what i used to tell isaac about my mom
and it's just that right now he's sick
and you know when he gets the help that
he needs he will get better
and you will be able to see him but
until then he needs to recover
let's talk a little about hobby how are
things with hobby
today things with avi are great today
we're getting along you know he's
coaching lincoln's football
and so things are good right now i have
no complaints
and what about joe and v things are
great you know vni just launched
um announced our podcast which is a
project that we've been kind of working
on
it's a pretty unorthodox uh
situation to be in where you are so
close
with your ex's now wife and i have to
tell you
a beautiful as a woman it is a beautiful
moment to see the two of you
so respectful of one another what did it
take for you to get to this place with v
if you would have asked me 10 years ago
do you think you and b will ever be
friends my answer would have been hell
no like
no i'm never going to be friends with
her but i think
v opened my eyes to co-parenting she
really
talked to me about what that looked like
to her growing up and i i was like oh
wow like they're really
this happens like there are people that
get along they put their differences
aside and they become friends or
at least civil and and so she really
opened my eyes to that
and i just have to tell you i don't know
if you ever read the youtube comments
but there is so much positivity
for joe the fans love joe they think
he's really risen to the occasion
as not only a great father but um people
really love how supportive he's been to
you how you've come to him
sometimes in your lower moments um and
he's been like a confidant
sort of how do you feel about your
relationship with joe today
i'm a good mom but my relationships
aren't always great and so
the combination of the two you know
sometimes my my decisions are
questionable
he really has supported me especially
when i came to him about being pregnant
with creed and even lux
um i didn't anticipate to get the
reaction that i did from him which was
full support and
and so i really am thankful for that
these past six months
have been the hardest probably of my
adult life
what has therapy done for you why is it
so important to you
therapy it's not just talking to someone
and getting things off your chest i mean
it's really
facing the music and looking at where
you're going wrong
next month will be a year of therapy for
me and i i can't stress enough how
how much progress i've made in such a
short time
and i seriously recommend therapy to
everyone is there one
moment in your life or one issue that
you feel like
wow we really worked through that in
therapy and i don't know if the outcome
would have been as successful as it is
today if i hadn't
addressed it so heavily in therapy yeah
i mean
there was something really um
traumatic that happened to me last
october and i haven't really talked
about what
what exactly it was but um
that's really kind of like the
the moment when i knew i needed to get
help and so
if i hadn't gone into therapy and worked
through that with a therapist i don't
know where i would be today i don't want
to pry or ask anything inappropriate but
i wouldn't be doing my job if i didn't
follow up with you um can you can you
share
what happened to you last doctor i don't
think i'm there yet i think
they're it's coming i'm almost to a
place where i want to share my story but
um it's you know domestic violence is a
real thing and it happens
more often than you think and so um
that's all i'm going to say about it
initial all of them yeah
all right we got a special delivery
awesome here's your keys
what does it mean to you to know that
you know you started out as a 16 year
old girl in this reality docu-series
and here you are today at 28 a
successful businesswoman
what is all that growth and and success
what does that mean to you
i hope that other people can look at my
story and be like okay kale came from
nothing she had no dad her mom was an
addict and an alcoholic
and you know when i first was on the
show i was on food stamps and scared to
tell
talk about it you know so i i really
hope that people can look at that and
say
they they can do anything they put their
mind to a lot of chatter around this
you recently joined only fans how is
that
how has that experience been so far you
know what it kind of just
that was one thing i can't stay
consistent in like i just don't
it was a joke i sent a couple feet picks
and then i haven't been on since
okay so can you just set the record
straight there there will be no
kale nudity no nothing um
untraditional i guess you could say post
it on there
yeah it's anything i've already the post
the pictures that i posted on there are
already on my instagram
so there's really there's really nothing
nothing to see there can i ask what your
prices are
500.
so if you got if you got a notification
today that someone would like another
foot pick would you take one this
afternoon oh absolutely
i sure would you have been
on on television and in the teen mom and
16 and pregnant universe
um for over a decade now i'm curious
how will you know when it's the right
time to walk away
when it becomes more of a stress in my
life like
filming is stressful but not stressful
enough to walk
i don't know i don't know that i can
answer that question until i'm
to that point do you feel like that day
could be sometime
soon or do you see this kind of being
like the long haul like you want to
continue showcasing your brand and your
evolution as a human being
as of right now i mean i would continue
as long as they're
they're asking me to and as long as
people are watching and it's and it's
you know still what it is um
but tomorrow that could change so we
don't really know
has there ever been a moment where you
you felt like
uh i regret signing up for reality tv
sometimes when when the heat is on us
and and we didn't make a huge a great
decision on tv i think
it's always like why did i do this you
know but the bigger picture is that we
have a good time with it we've met
really cool people we've had we've
inspired people
we've lowered the teen pregnancy rates
and so you look at the bigger picture
you're like okay i did this for all the
right reasons
you know i think it's so interesting
that you're you're on a show
called teen mom too but if we break it
down
you're a 28 year old very
successful stable woman mother of four
do you think that there's any stigma
with still being labeled a teen mom
when you're all of those things that i
just mentioned yeah i mean i think
people forget
a lot of the times when you know when
they find out oh she's having another
baby or even
chelsea who's married they're like four
kids like what are you doing you're on a
show called team mom they expect us to
not grow up and be able to
have other relationships and other
children they think of
us in their minds as still 16 and
pregnant um and then they also are like
well
you wouldn't have all that you had if it
wasn't for teen mom and it's like okay
but what is the alternative the
alternative
to not launching yourself in different
directions is to what sit around collect
you know your check from mtv and and
wait for the money to run out like
no you want to launch yourself into
different directions and kind of you
know
make yourself successful another way so
do you think the label of teen mom has
been detrimental to you in any way
um a little bit i think there there
definitely have been companies that are
like
oh you know kale did this on teen mom or
or whatever
just because it is there's a stigma to
it you know you think
team mom and and you know maybe they're
not educated or
or they're not successful or they can't
be successful and so i try to just
prove them wrong as much as i can oh my
girls got a degree
we applaud that
look amazing you think you're very
transparent about this
health journey that you've gone on can
you tell me like
what is it that you're trying to achieve
and like where are you at with your
journey
i'm 28 and my body is not the same as it
once was
i just i would really love to go into
you know give myself these two years and
go enter my 30s
the healthiest and you know the fittest
i've ever been and so that's kind of the
goal for me is to
drop all the unnecessary weight be fit
and feel good about myself because i do
have four kids that i have to keep up
with
is there a number like that you're
fixated on that i gotta drop this amount
of weight or i wanna get to this certain
weight
yeah i think i think 50 pounds would be
a good goal for me
being an entrepreneur being a mother is
there any time for love
um not right now i think that i'm still
healing from a lot of the things like i
was
mentioning before i really just kind of
want to focus on myself and and try to
be the best version of me before i bring
someone else into
the show so many years of teen mom
teen mom 2 16 and pregnant you have had
some really memorable quotes and i would
just love to get your reaction
hold my foot joe i don't think people
understand my
he let go of my foot i needed that
pressure i needed
him i needed to be able to push off his
hand
to give birth okay
i hope he held v's foot when she was
giving birth
too he better not have let go did you
know that that was gonna be such a funny
moment
no i didn't and i there's there's
definitely accounts dedicated to that
quote and so
um i just wish that they understood like
i really needed him to do that for me
and he let me down
wise words to women all over the planet
giving birth make sure a partner is
there to hold your foot